[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> So here I am at Heathrow, and I am -- as
you can see outside, it's
sort of almost dawn.
I'm just pleased the day is here actually
because there's been a lot of
prep to get to this point.
I've realized as well this was a year since
I got back from Ethiopia
almost to the day.
So it seems sort of fitting that, you know,
the same day I got back, a
year later I'm flying out to hopefully get
people to take notice.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> We're on our way to Davos which will take
about an hour and half,
two hours, apparently.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
>> It's night one in Davos and as you can
see it's absolutely
beautiful.
It's snowing gently, the air is really crystal
clear and fresh.
And it's just absolutely amazing.
And actually, what springs to mind for me
is the juxtaposition with my
Ethiopia experience.
And what I wonder is some of the world leaders
who are here, they must
spend a lot of their lives talking about poverty,
but they have ever
actually experienced it?
Have they ever actually gone into slums and
seen how people live?
And I suppose that's what is on my mind at
the moment is really holding
those girls' voices and those African experiences
with me here as we go
forward.
I'm about to do an interview on CNN so that
hopefully will go global.
So the message is getting out.
>>Female genital mutilation, commonly know
as FGM, is a ancient custom
often tied to religious and social acceptance.
And now Julia
Lalla-Maharajh is bringing it to the attention
of world at the World
Economic Forum in Davos.
>>My belief is that issues like this can't
stay on the margins, that
they really have to be debated at the highest
levels.
It's the end of day one, it's been a really
long day.
And I'm the proud owner of a white badge,
which is quite phenomenal in
Davos.
It basically means access to all areas.
But today's been a set up, so it's really
tomorrow morning where
everything happens.
It will be talking about people.
It will be working out how to say to them
about female genital
mutilation in a way that makes them want to
listen.
So, yeah.
A good day and looking forward to tomorrow.
It's -- I'll let you know how it goes.